auf seinem Ultraschallgerät hat Dr Peter
Rott immer den vollen Durchblick wenn er
aber in die Zukunft denkt wird der
Berliner Frauenarzt schnell unwirsch
immer mehr Bürokratie immer weniger Zeit
für seine Patientinnen rot sagt es
reicht ich verstehe meinen Arztberuf so
dass eine arztptientenbeziehung ja davon
lebt dass ich mit der Patientin Rede und
mich um die Patientin kümmer und nicht
dass ich in den Computer reinhacke so
wie Peter geht es vielen ziehen ein
Ärztestreik deshalb in vielen deutschen
Städten es fordert leider drastische
Maßnahmen um zu versuchen der Politik
klar zumachen dass so nicht weitergeht
der Gesundheitsminister beschwichtigt
per Kurznachricht die Hausärzte fordern
einen Krisengipfel die Praxen sind
überfüllt es gibt zu viel Bürokratie
diesen Krisengipfel werden wir im Januar
machen Vorschläge zuur notwendigen
Entbürokratisierung und zu einer
Honorarreform werden schon seit Monaten
vorbereitetü üendeckung für den Minister
kommt von den Kassen sie haben kein
Verständnis für den Streik hier werden
Brückentage genutzt die die Patient
Patienten gerade bei diesem Hochstand an
Atemwegserkrankung dringend bräuchten
und was man nicht vergessen darf ab 1
Januar steigen die Honorare der Ärztin
und Ärzte das heißt 2 Milliarden Euro
sind bereits als zusatzhonnerer
vereinbart kein Verständnis für diesen
Streik viele ärzteeverbände aber
verlieren so langsam die Geduld mit der
Politik Situation in den Praxen
verschlechtert sich immer mehr
Leistungen müssen gekürzt werden es
entstehen Wartelisten lange Wartezeiten
auf Facharzt und hausarztermine das muss
ich ändern und dafür kämpfen wir
Patienten die in den nächsten Tagen
ärztliche Hilfe brauchen sollten deshalb
den Notdienst anrufen unter der
bundesweit gültigen Rufnummer 116
117 jatausende arztprxen sind zwischen
den Jahren also geschlossen über den
Frust der Ärzte spreche ich jetzt mit
Gesundheitsminister da Lauterbach guten
Abend Herr
Lauterbach hallo guten Abend der
wirchobund wirft ihn ja vor auf
bisherrige Protestmaßnahmen nicht
reagiert zu haben halten Sie die
Forderung der niedergelassenen Ärzte
nach mehr Geld für
gerechtfertigt also es geht ja nicht nur
um mehr Geld sondern auch um
Bürokratieabbau und seit Monaten
arbeiten wir ja an einem Gesetz zum
Bürokratieabbau in den letzten Jahren
hat sich eine enorme Bürokratie die in
den Praxen aufgebaut das muss jetzt ein
Ende haben daran arbeiten wir schon
einige Zeit das wissen die Ärzte ja auch
die Forderung nach mehr Geld hatte ich
nicht für begründet außer in der Schweiz
wird natürlich in Europa in den Praxen
nirgendwo so gut verdient wie in
Deutschland daher die Spielräume für
honorarzuwechsel die sehe ich nicht aber
die Forderung nach einer
Entbürokratisierung der Praxen die ist
richtig und der kommen wir bekanntlich
ja auch nach mit diesem Argument werden
sie die Ärzte aber nicht überzeugen
können weil Geld wird gefordert was
sagen sie
den also in der Tat äh Geldforderungen
stehen im Raum
äh wir haben hier tatsächlich eine
Ungleichverteilung der Honorare und
sicherlich ist es richtig dass z.B bei
den Hausärzten eine entbudgettierung
notwendig ist das haben wir auch schon
angekündigt daran arbeiten wir ja das
gleiche haben wir bei den Kinderärzten
auch schon gemacht aber viele
fachartsgruppen beispielsweise
Radiologen äh oder Orthopäden verdienen
im internationalen Vergleich
ausgezeichnet und es hat auch wieder ein
Zuwachs im letzten Jahr gegeben somit
kann ich da die Forderung nicht sehen es
gibt andere Berufsgruppen im
Gesundheitssystem beispielsweise
Pflegekräfte wo also tatsächlich da mehr
Bedarf ist aber die Honorarforderung
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen ich weiß
dass die im Raum steht die
endbürokratisierung das ist eine
berechtigte Forderung die seit Jahren
hätte erfüllt werden müssen die
Forderung nach mehr Geld bleibt aber
trotzdem im Raum stehen und es ist ja so
dass eine Möglichkeit für die Ärzte mehr
Geld zu verdienen wäre ja die Neuauflage
der neupatientenregelung zeigen sie sich
da
gesprächsbereit nein und zwar deshalb
weil die Neupatienten Regelung die habe
ich ja damals selbst mit eingeführt sie
hat sich einfach nicht bewährt sie hat
einfach nur mehr Geld für die gleichen
Besuche der Patienten in den Praxen
gebracht es hat eben keine verbesserte
Versorgung mit permin gegeben dafür
haben wir eine andere Regelung
eingeführt die jetzt auch wirkt die ist
einfach preiswerter und sie wirkt
weshalb sollte ich eine teurere Regel
wieder einführen die uns einfach nicht
gedient hat die neupatientenregelung
wird sicherlich nicht das Ergebnis unser
Zusammenkunft sein im übrigen verstehe
ich auch nicht weshalb gestreigt wird
weil die Forderungen der Patienten sind
wir müssen versorgt werden wir haben
derzeit eine riesige Krankheitswelle in
der Bevölkerung die Forderung der Ärzte
nach mehr Geld sind auch auch bekannt
der Streik bringt überhaupt nichts nach
vorne wir haben ja schon ein Treffen
einen Gipfel vereinbart im Januar genau
lassen wir lassen Sie uns über diesen
Gipfel sprechen was genau wird da
erwartet also wenn sich da mit den
Verbänden der Hausärzte Treffen soll es
da nur um einen formellen Austausch
geben oder
haben Sie da auch vor konkrete Ansagen
zu
machen ja natürlich haben wir etwas
vorbereitet wir arbeiten ja seit Monaten
an einem Gesetz wo für Hausärzte diese
endbudgettierung kommen soll wo wir uns
auch mit der Frage der
arznahmittelregresse auseinandersetzen
werden wo wir uns mit dem
Bürokratieabbau auseinandersetzen werden
da sind ja über sehr viele Jahre
Probleme entstanden hat eine Reformstau
gegeben wie auch in vielen anderen
Bereichen unseres Gesundheitssystems da
gehen wir ja heran das Gesetz wird seit
Monaten bearbeitet darüber werden wir
reden wir werden unsere Gedanken da
vorstellen wir werden das diskutieren
aber also es ist nicht also vergleichbar
mit einer Tarifverhandlung oder
ähnliches sondern im Großen und Ganzen
steht hier im Raum die Praxen brauchen
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen brauchen
weniger Bürokratie das Geld muss auch
gerechter verteilt werden aber einfach
mehr Geld in ein System zu schütten wie
in der Vergangenheit was nicht wirklich
gut funktioniert diese Lösung haben wir
einfach zu oft praktiziert die wird
nicht im Vordergrund stehen so die
Einschätzung und Äußerung vom
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach ich
gehe davon aus dass viele Ärzte mit
dieser Einschätzung nicht zufrieden sind
vielen Dank dennoch für das Gespräch
heute abend
merci danke Ihnen